What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
We are super excited to announce
That we have just launched our first Pongfinity table tennis products!
In today's video we are going to show you this net
Which can turn almost anything into a table tennis table!
And we also have our very own professional level Pongfinity ball!
You can buy these from Pongfinity.store
And during the first 24 hours
We have got a special campaign for you guys
Where every single order gets a greeting card signed by all three of us
We are going to play a match using this net
Where every point will be on a different table
Let's go!
The cabinet!
You saved it!
I got like a side spin or something!
Okay next up, a chopping board!
This looks pretty difficult!
Jackpot!
Straight in the eye!
Sorry
Treasure chest
You got it!
Around the net!
Why did I have to go for the hard one?
I have got this
I have got this!
It's my point!
This is intense
Sorry!
Okay next is the oven tray!
It's a good sound in this!
Okay this table is a bit bigger!
It hit the lower level
It went into the sink
Next up, the pot lid!
I like this
It's making it quite easy
Wait a second
Who won the point?
How did I manage to loose that?
You were in control of the table
I have got the tray, I could do anything!
Okay, car roof!
This is something I haven't tried before
It's in!
I got it on!
I blocked it with my nose!
I have to see the slow motion
It's in!
I got it on!
Ok, I'll give you the point
The sea gull is cheering for me
Or me
I took the side spin
A window
Nice save
I'm moving you around
Got it with a lucky point
Can you handle the swaying?
Easily
I'm going to fishing
Okay good game!
We had so much fun filming this
You guys have to get your own
from Pongfinity.store
We have been working really hard to make this happen
So hopefully you guys enjoy our products
Making an order will also be a big support to our channel
So head over to Pongfinity.store!
Until next time!